>> RorELL, RELIEVED AND
LESS AFRAID AN THEDITHIS
TI L.
IF YOU CAN IMAGI TIME ST YEAS FL
ERE N FROM THE
RTH, THE WE RSFR KYIV.E OF BEING
STE LAST YEAR.
HED
THEMK,
NOW  HEAOME THAT,
YES, THEY WEREFIED BACK
THEY DIDOTW HECAPITOL OR THEIR
GOT TO ASK HIM AN ABOUT ND
HOW LONG HE THOUGHT THISAR
WOULD
D IN L
YOU SPOKE TO YOUR OWN FORCES ANI
THIS YEAR.
YOU HAVE H T WESTERN IENDS, YOUL
ONG AS ITAKES.
YOU OWTHE RUSSIAN LEADER
BELIEVES THAT TIMES ON HIS
WHY DO TT IT'S
Y THE OF
ANW E  AS LONG AS AK
IAN PERSCTranslator: THANK YOU
IF EACH OF EACPAY AS
ONE FISTE STRONGIS
ORY , TOTHEIR TERMS AND  NOT JT
, , , I BELIEV
WE PARTNERS,
PARTNERS, AND ERE IS EVIDENCE
IFE  IMPORTANT RKY WI
INEVITABLE.
CERTAIN THE WILL BE
VICTORY.
BRIANNA
WE NEED WEAPONS  DEFENELVES.
EY SAY IT'S GOINPEEDWE NEED THEE
ON
OF STRENGTH SO THAT
HAVE
WAR FROM POSITION OF STRENGTH.
EYRRENDER AND THEY NOT TAKE RUS
NOW, THE
BRIANNA?
>>HRE IN
KYIV.THANK YOU.
ARE STANDING BWI MORE ON  TO STU
GENERAL WESLEY.
IN A N
ALONWIIX FR NA
SUPRNDERS,
NOW IS TE IC
NEED AND HOW COULDT AN FOR.
OUTCOME OF TWAR?
A NEGOTIATION BUTCE E
REFLECTINGTL
CONDITIONS.
WH
PUT CRIM
OVERRUN CRIMEA.E
PUTIN WILL COME TO THE T, O THAT
PIECES O NEETAICND
SS WE IND OF BEDG TOWARD IS
THINK WE'RE GOIN GET AT THBARGA
GET ON THE
UNLIKELY.
>> JIMWE KNOW PUTIN TH.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNIN Reporter:H
IS DRONES CO IMPACTF
AMMUNI A CONTINUES AN
INTENSE ARTILLERY BATT REAY
ETE
DR A.
WE'VE SEEN THE IRA
S IN TERMS OF HELP
SSVIS
COUNTRY.E BIGGEST THREAT IS CHI
HELP WILL LENGTHEN T
NEEDS NOW, PARTICULARLY WHAT W .
THE OTHER PIECE HAE
BROAD, AND THAT IS THAU HA HER
WAEEN THE U.S. AND
ALLIES AND
YO WESTERN OFFICIAL EI
WAYAND ITE SIDE, N R
SIDE WITH CHINA DE
PRTO, YOU WOULD NOW HAVE TPER P
R IN
TO THE BROADER CONFLICT GOING ON
BETWEEN THE SURS
NUMBER OF FRONT
CONFLICT AND ALSO ADD THE SK
ESCALATION BEYOND THE BDE
>> CYN, YOU HAD
NSE SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN
AB
YOU?
>> YEAH.
THISE , THAT CHINA I
IO PREPARING T THIS, THATY'RE C
BUT IT OBVIOUSLY
QUESTION TO WHING
E,
WE KNOW WHAT CONSEQUS MEAN, WHAL
OW B THINK FD VERYP
BE FS IF R
T KIND O
ASSISTANCE FROM CHW,, T WA
TOO  LEAR THA CHINA HAS A T OFY
MUNIHEOU
SUBSTANTIAL SUPPT TO RUSSIA,
PCONFLICT.
CONCERN THERE,T ITLD
PROLONG THE CONFLICT.
AUSTIN TOLME, BRIANNA, THAT
HE -- THAT UNGS TO CHI
BASICAY  NOT TIDE LETHAL ASSISTA
BUT ONE THING WEHOULD NOTES STI
N                             U
BALLOO
THN NTHS.ERPDI  CALL.
IT'S CING THAT THE
NTAGON CHIEF CANNOS UNTERP OE E.
INTELLIGENCE SRUSSIA'S GOAL
AS THEY SEE IT ITO CAPTU A LUHA
EOMIS
OU KNOWY
DID KE LUHANSK AND DAN
DOUBT THAT WOULD BE THE ENOF
IT.
F THEYHOSE, I
BELIEVE PUTIN WOULCO ENTIRE
COUNTRY OR CON I S
NOW THLD YOUW,WE'RE HAVING A SE
INFL, T ERNOT BELIEVE,AT
HE'S G SATISFIEDH HERE AREN DO T
E COULD TRY
ST OF UKRAINORD CREATE TROUBLE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
ANAT
SEEING RUSSI HE COULD HA NOW, G'
SHELL ACROSS THE EAST ANTHUP HAV
TAKEN CONT SUBB
WHAT WILL YO WG FOR
HERE IN THCO
E QUESTIONW
AT MOVING INTO THENE IG
CASUALTIES ALO
RUSSIAN RATE O FOR THIS TO WBAT
GOT TO BE LDCT
S HAVE
FOT THEY'LL USTOO THTHE PLAN, A
TO P PRESSURE IANS THAT THEY CA
MATATY OF THEI
SO THAT'S  WATCHIN
FOR.
CARAINIANS HOLD AS?
WE G ENOUG
AMMUNI, AND IS
OFFENSIVE TH CRIMEA CO
THATOUL
TI
TANKS.
TANKS ARRIVED INBRAM TAKOPARD
R ACCORDING TOFFICIALS, MAYBE NT
YEAR, WELL INTXT
IS THIS E ENOUGH TO
E?
AIM IS TO
RCES AOFKEISH BRADLEY
FIGHTING VLEELUROPEAN VERSIONS
THOSE.
NOW YOHAN MADE
PU ND TO GIVE THHEILY AND
K IMEA. Y SO N ST AND THEY MBIT
CIHEY BELIEVE EY CAN
T IN THE COMING MONTHS.
YOU HAVE THESE
MINISTER SPEAKING ABOUPOIBNGD TM
NOF THEY'RE
CONFT
THEY HAVE A F INIBAND DEFENSE O
WOULD SAY U.S. OFFICLS A
TIY WHISTIEN THEY CAN GAIN